we did this right along remote where we
have a driving student out and some
sweet girls yeah great
diana chang and some some stuff happened
some of it legal some of it maybe not we
don't know
but the important thing is we had a good
time and nobody learned anything about
driving so let's take a look at some of
the outtakes right now Cole does that
same jacket did you that one yeah this
is the same jacket okay
things are great on the show I just I've
had this jacket a long time they look
great why do you need the same jacket
that's not good surprise here to pick
apart my wardrobe
a young woman how to drive you got some
good insurance for this damn stunt you
trying today do we have insurance on
this you actually have great insurance
imagine in really good shape I don't
know if you guys notice tonight but I
have eight and a half percent body fat
is that true yes some people say it
looks like somebody drew my body that's
what they say who said that I did okay
no one else said that you hit somebody
I'm out I'm running I'm not gonna be a
part of it and cube I suggest you do the
same thing I will tear ass out of this
car
you will tear ass funny I will tear ass
the situation poni were you aware you
did something that you had to get out of
there there was a time when I rented
video cassette and it was overdue he
didn't bring it back and then I went to
the same video store and they were like
you still owe us Sleepless in Seattle
and I just tore ass I've lived a life
let's put it that way watch this no look
this is called [ __ ] to somebody it's a
it's a it's a when I tell you to go go
go go
this seatbelt stop it's for sucks okay
happen go out like a G you'll need this
all the time we look stupid okay I did
tell her then if you're gonna go out go
out like a G Diana yeah Diana drop next
to somebody if you don't find the person
for me to throw this vignette
system around here any cute couple in
there before yeah I've been there
I told you I'm from the streets that's
back when I first came out to LA and
they didn't respect me let me guess it
was a G thing I had one about me saying
was it a G thing
no it's just something that Y guys
probably only say when they're around
black guys I'm gonna be honest I don't
say that a lot till there's nothing
today and you don't use your horn enough
use your horn Diana right now give it
just one more no no it's not rhythm
today I had a honky with rhythm look see
that that's how black people home no
that was white yeah
it's like a song you like that cube you
like that son
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you